ann sekulas isn't coming to the uk
but she is to face british justice
nineteen-year-old harry dunn was killed
in a collision with the former cia
officer outside raf croton in
northamptonshire a u.s spy base
since she left the uk claiming
diplomatic immunity harry's family have
campaigned for her to face a trial
they're completely overwhelmed at the
moment there's lots of tears and it's
really been the culmination of a
you know a long arduous and tireless
campaign it's over two and a half years
since we lost harry although this
development is is welcome news none of
us must
forget that mrs succules is entitled to
a fair hearing
in 2019 harry's parents even met
president trump to ask for help but
after anser kulas was charged with
causing death by dangerous driving the
u.s refused to extradite her
the two sides have already reached
agreement in the civil claim for damages
in the united states but harry's family
have always said that this is about the
principle of anser kulas facing british
justice
that will now happen when she appears
via video link from america at
westminster magistrates court on january
the 18th
lisa dowd sky news